what's at stake is huge it's really our
livelihoods it's our health it's our
economies we know that there are more
than a billion people who lack safe
water in the world if you don't have
energy you can still live if you don't
have water picking up right now you turn
on the tap and you don't even think
about it I think it's important to
develop especially among our students
our community some critical thinking
about these issues it's actually
important for all scientists and
engineers from all disciplines to be
asking themselves how it is that their
expertise could be brought to this
problem of clean water I'm totally
impressed with this generation of
students in their commitment to
addressing poverty in inequity in the
world climate change population growth
increased urbanization are posing
significant risks to the renewable water
supply around the world and anyway that
not just technologists and engineers but
also policymakers entrepreneurs
investors can try to mitigate those
risks would do our earth and our
humanity a real service water supply is
under a great deal of pressure and yet
most of the Earth's surface is covered
with water and so if there is a way for
us to make that water usable drinkable
are good for irrigating crops then we
can help to relieve the pressures on
water supply worldwide
we're already seeing countries like
Israel countries like Saudi Arabia
leveraging the technology of
desalination to supply clean drinking
water to their populations the research
that we're doing is more about how you
loopback water systems so it's not so
much a linear approach as it is a
cyclical approach where water is being
used it's also being cleaned and treated
and it goes back into the system as
opposed to being put back into an ocean
where we can't really get it back
without great effort and cost him the
hardest problems today in energy and
water are inherently multidisciplinary
and a summit like this allows people
from different walks of life to come
together who are interested in this
problem and think together about it and
learn about what's going on across the
disciplines and get new ideas and get
inspiration kind of galvanizing the
water community on campus